okay so over on uk tv over on itv which
is a big channel
over in the uk piers morgan was on good
morning britain
again piers morgan is a big critic of
meghan markle he has been for quite a
while
he was kind of friendly with meghan
markle for a while apparently and then
she
apparently ghosted him after she got
involved with prince harry
and she was kind of nasty to him and
this is you know according to according
to piers
and then he didn't like the way that she
was treating the royal family apparently
she was trying to throw her weight
around inside the royal family she
didn't respect a lot of the traditions
and so morgan's been a longtime critic
of
of meghan markle now full disclosure i'm
friendly with peers now
i mean that is the hilarious of our the
hilarious hilarity of our current
political moment is that anyone
who doesn't buy into every narrative of
the woke is now on one side and the
walker on the other
that is the way this works so anyway
piers morgan was very critical
of meghan markle on the show he said i
don't believe a word that comes out of
her mouth
right the direct quote from piers morgan
is he said
that if she i wouldn't believe it if she
read me a weather report
he was talking about her report that not
only was she suicidal but that she went
to members of the palace
and that they basically dismissed her
complaints about being suicidal he said
who did you go to what did they say to
you
i'm sorry i don't believe a word she
said meghan markle i wouldn't believe it
if she read me a weather report
okay now this resulted in a massive
outpouring of criticism because how dare
peters morgan say that in his opinion he
doesn't believe meghan markle
you must believe right as don lemon says
she fits all the categories so you must
believe you don't even have to check the
story you don't have to find out the
other side
okay so this resulted yesterday in piers
morgan on good morning britain
getting into a spat with this guy who is
apparently like the weather guy
on good morning britain on itv who
basically
said that morgan's take on the situation
was disgusting and piers got mad and
walked off the show
i understand that you've got a personal
relationship
with market or had one and she cut you
off
she's entitled to cut you off if she
wants to
has she said anything about you since
she cut you off i don't think she has
but yet you continue
to trash her okay i'm done with this no
no sorry no
actually do you know what that's
possible but not mine no no no no no no
no
i'm being sorry absolutely
diabolical behavior diabolical first of
all gotta love the brits
so he goes after morgan morgan walks off
the show
and now morgan's out of a job now the
reason that morgan is out of job is not
because he walked off the show
the reason that morgan is out of a job
is because the government started to
investigate itv
and you know who's a person who put in a
complaint to itv
our great victim the victim of the hour
meghan markle
because nothing says victimhood quite
like trying to exercise institutional
power in order to get somebody fired
that is definitely a good thing to do
apparently
according to the hollywood reporter
meghan markle filed an itv
complaint against piers morgan which is
not
babyish behavior at all somebody
criticizes you on tvs you file a
complaint with their bosses
i'm sorry that's childish behavior under
any circumstances that has
i've received more than my share of
criticism over the course of my career
i'm a public figure that's the way that
it works i cannot remember
filing a complaint with somebody's boss
asking to have them disciplined for
something they said about me
in fact i have a number of fairly good
friends
whose friendships were initiated by them
writing something crappy about me in a
fairly prominent place and me reaching
out and saying i appreciated them
listening to the stuff even though i
think they got it wrong
okay but not meghan markle apparently
according to the hollywood reporter
neither itv nor archwell have denied
that a complaint was lodged on behalf of
the duchess meghan markle made a formal
complaint to itv
following piers morgan's incendiary
comments about the duchess the uk
broadsheet newspapers have reported both
the guardian and the telegraph claim
a complaint was lodged on behalf of the
royal after monday's episode of good
morning britain
in which morgan repeatedly lashed out at
prince harry and markle over their
revelations
in the explosive interview with oprah
winfrey the growing fuhrer over the
former cnn hosts tyrade
one that also saw him storm offset after
being rebuked on air by a colleague
would ultimately lead to him quitting
the breakfast news show with itv making
the announcement he was standing down on
tuesday evening
among morgan's most controversial
comments was that he didn't believe
markle's claims she had felt suicidal
and had reached out for support from
buckingham palace only for it to be
rejected okay so he didn't actually say
i don't believe that you felt to his
title right he didn't actually say that
if you go back and watch the comments
what he said is i don't believe a word
she says which is a
pretty blanket statement and what he
specifically cited was he didn't believe
that she had gone to the palace and the
palace had been like
yeah you're suicidal well you know if
something bad happens that's kind of on
you it's gonna look bad for the family
if we bring in a psychiatrist like they
have their own medical team
inside buckingham palace okay the
comments drew
widespread condemnation including from a
mental health charity and led to more
than 41 000 complaints
to regulator ofcom okay and this is
where this becomes relevant for
americans
okay because we are now living in a
world in the united states
where many many people in america want
an american version of ofcom
so what exactly is ofcom so ofcom
is a regulatory agency who sees its job
as to regulate the way that media is
done
okay ofcom is a uh is again a government
agency
that is designed to regulate what people
can and cannot say
in december of 2020 the regulator
launched a review of what protections
were in place
with regard to mental health and
well-beings of individuals who take part
in their show the commons digital
culture media and sports select
committee
has launched inquiries into the reality
tv industry for example
ofcom creates measures aimed at
protecting vulnerable people and others
not being used to not used to being in
the public eye
ofcom has its own director of standards
and audience protection
okay and so ofcom which is again this
british agency which regulates it's sort
of like the fcc except it has an
enormous power of
over over actual broadcast in a way that
the fcc really does not
ofcom is the office of communications
it's the government-approved regulatory
and competition authority for
broadcasting telecommunications
and again they have wide ability to
punish people for saying things they
don't like
so apparently there's an official
investigation
by ofcom by the uk media regulator based
on appears morgan saying he didn't
believe meghan markle
which is nuts that's an opinion by piers
morgan
how do you get investigated for an
opinion i'm confused
see here in america we have this thing
called freedom of speech and the first
amendment is pretty great
in britain they don't have the same
thing european standards of speech are
very different this is why they hate
speech regulations
they seek to measure harm of speech
against value of speech which of course
is a completely subjective decision
there's no limiting principle to it and
so ofcom does this on a regular basis
according to variety ofcom launched an
investigation after more than 41 000
people wrote in to complain
about itv's good morning britain host
piers morgan's comments on meghan markle
so first of all
who gives a crap right in the united
states if a bunch of people wrote in
to the fcc about me having an opinion
about meghan markle
you know what the result would be
nothing because we have a first
amendment in this country thank god
they don't have the same thing in
britain on monday's edition of the show
of course
morgan made his comments and so now
ofcom was apparently investigating an
ofcom spokesperson told variety we have
quote launched an investigation into
monday's episode under good morning
britain
under our harm and offense rules harm
and offense rules
okay like the fact you have harm and
offense rules
in a supposedly free country means that
your country is not nearly as free as
you are pretending that it is
now morgan did come back on the air on
tuesday before the walk-off and he said
when we talked about this yesterday i
said
as an all-encompassing thing i don't
believe what meghan markle is saying
generally in this interview and i still
have serious concerns about the veracity
of a lot of what she said but let me
just state for the record on my position
on mental illness and on suicide these
are clearly extremely serious things and
should be taken extremely seriously and
if someone is feeling that way they
should get the treatment and help they
need every time and if they belong to an
institution like the royal family and
they go and seek that help they should
absolutely be given it
it's not for me to question if she felt
suicidal i'm not in her mind and that is
for her to say
my real concern was a disbelief that she
went to a senior member of the royal
household and told them she was suicidal
and was told she couldn't have any help
because it would be a bad look for the
family if that's true first that person
should be fired and second the royal
family had serious questions that need
to be answered
but that apparently didn't fix the
problem right morgan still had to go
because morgan had offended the woke
princess and the wolf princess the
powerless victimized woke princess
and her fans got him fired and got an
investigation going
from the office of communications in the
uk
okay it's usually pretty easy to tell
who is a victim and who is the
victimizer in a situation
like this the way that you can tell is
who is the person who is threatening to
actually do something to another person
that's how you can tell the actual
victim is here and meghan markle
was not threatened by piers morgan in
any way he had an opinion
his opinion said that he didn't believe
a lot of what made meghan markle to say
and
i frankly agree with a lot of that i
don't agree with a lot of i don't
believe some of what meghan markle had
to say either
i find it largely self-serving
but the fact is that that in our culture
if you claim victimhood
this apparently gives you ultimate power
to actually harm other people see here's
the thing we now live in a society where
if piers morgan says something that
offends meghan markle that is considered
harm if meghan markle files a complaint
with itv with the intent of getting
piers morgan fired that is not an actual
so one loses their job the other has
their feelings a little bit hurt
and uh one is considered a very very
serious harm now how do we determine
what the harm is we simply look to
intersectionality we determine who's
more woke if you're woke you're a victim
even if you're the victimizer you're the
victim that's the way this works now
the woke are the actual royalty the woke
are the actual american and apparently
british royalty
because now you have to be treated the
way that royalty ought to be treated no
one can say a word against you
and if a word is said against you you
will be investigated maybe you will be
fired
piers morgan did put out a statement
he uh on twitter he said on monday i
said i didn't believe meghan markle in
her oprah interview i've had time to
reflect on this opinion and i still
don't
if you did okay freedom of speech is a
hill i'm happy to die on
thanks for all of the love and the hate
i'm off to spend more time with my
opinions
and then he quoted winston churchill
some people's idea of free speech that
they are free to say what they like but
if anyone says anything back that is an
outrage
he later doubled down he said i don't
believe anything that comes out of her
mouth i think the damage he's done to
the british monarchy into the queen at a
time when prince philip is lying in the
hospital is enormous
and frankly contemptible if i have to
follow my sword for expressing an
honestly held opinion about meghan
markle and that diatribe of bilge that
she came out with in that interview so
be it
i think it's fair to say although the
woke crowd will think they've canceled
me i think they'll be rather
disappointed
when i re-emerge okay so the woke being
the actual
western royalty at this point and you
can't say a word against the woke
because if you disagree with the woke
this proves that you are unwoke and
therefore unfit for public consumption
piers morgan losing his job over saying
that he disagrees with meghan markle and
doesn't believe her
that is not an actual harm piers morgan
having said he doesn't believe her
is the actual harm because of course she
is not just a princess she's a woke
princess
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content